c'est le beau bonjour bonjour monsieur
roi dans une école toute neuve flambant
neuve ouais effectivement il y a 4 ans
lors du premier mandat j'avais demandé à
Jean-François Robert je dessiner entre
autres en s'inspirant de ce que Ricardo
est compagnie avait fait un nouveau
modèle d'école plus lumineuse avec plus
d'espace commun et sa première fois que
j'en visite une le qui est ouverte
depuis le mois de septembre c'est
vraiment beau bon en même temps c'est
l'exception à la règle on est entré dans
construire une centaine c'est certain
que graduellement on voudrait que toutes
les écoles au Québec soient comme ça
mais effectivement il y en a seulement
une centaine à peu près la moitié qui
ont besoin beaucoup d'amour pour lui
dire positivement allez-vous accélérer
ce que vous deviez mettre en 5-6 ans
pour rénover les écoles ouais j'ai
demandé à Bernard drinville de revoir
comment on met dans différentes
catégories les écoles parce que quand on
dit il y en a 50% qui sont pas en bon
état qu'elles sont celles qui doivent
absolument être faites actuellement bon
il y a des enjeux de main d'oeuvre en
construction mais
écoutez pour moi ça a priorité donc je
veux pas qu'on s'empêche d'accélérer la
rénovation des écoles pour des raisons
d'argent il y a rien plus important pour
moi ce Drainville va présenter c'est son
plan de match demain à votre cocus mais
vous le fait que vous soyez ici
aujourd'hui avant votre focus et que
vous voulez envoyer le message que
l'éducation vous avez pas oublié ça mais
bon effectivement je le dis je le répète
oui l'environnement c'est important oui
la santé est importante mais il reste
que pour moi la priorité des priorités
c'est l'éducation déjà en premier mandat
oublions pas on a augmenté salaire des
enseignants de 18%, c'est la première
fois qu'on donnait pas la même
augmentation de salaire à tout le monde
on a ajouté 2000 octophonistes
orthopédagogue etc etc mais maintenant
on a encore des défis oui à rénovation
des écoles mais aussi le recrutement
d'enseignants donc meilleur salaire on
donne des bourses aux étudiants qui
étudient en éducation
il y a encore des gros défis en
éducation est-ce que ce serait pas le
moment monsieur le groupe parce que vous
le voyez dans plusieurs régions à
Joliette au lac Saint-Jean ailleurs les
gens disent on va être obligé de fermer
les maternelles 4 ans ils manquent de
prof il manque d'enseignants est-ce que
ce serait pas le moment de faire une
pause puis de regrouper vos enseignants
là où on en a le plus besoin j'ai vu
votre débat monsieur Roy sur les
maternelles 4 ans puis moi je suis 100%
d'accord monsieur Royer
un enfant qui a des difficultés
d'apprentissage il y en a 25% il faut
agir tout on a même un livre qui était
écrit il y a longtemps tout se joue
avant six ans donc à l'âge de 4 ans
si j'ai un enfant qui a des difficultés
d'apprentissage c'est mieux de l'envoyer
à la maternelle 4 ans parce que c'est
dans une école comme si il y en a où il
y a des orthophonistes puis où il y a
des enseignants qui ont quatre années
d'université de formation donc je
comprends que des avantages des gardes
de vie parce qu'elles sont ouvertes 12
mois par année etc mais il reste que
pour les enfants qui ont des difficultés
je voudrais que tous les enfants de 4
ans qui ont des difficultés accès à la
maternelle 4 ans il y a des enjeux
d'enseignants mais il y a des enjeux
d'enseignants alors les commissions les
centres de scolaires vous disent on n'a
pas les moyens dans certains cas on va
être obligé de fermer alors oui je
comprends ce que vous dites en absolu
dans un monde idéal oui mais on études
moyennes nos ambitions mais d'abord
c'est pas la même situation dans chaque
région dans chaque commission scolaire
il y a des endroits où on va être
capable d'ajouter les maternelles 4 ans
mettez notre objectif c'est d'en ajouter
partout et bon Bernard Rainville en
train de regarder puis vous en parlera
peut-être demain d'avoir plus de
flexibilité peut-être qu'on n'est pas
obligé dans une maternelle 4 ans d'avoir
un enseignant qui a fait quatre ans
d'université il y a peut-être des
compromis
bon la qualité du français vous avez vu
cette semaine ça a choqué beaucoup de
gens les l'examen de l'angle de
secondaire 5 de français le taux d'échec
est vraiment élevé inquiétant est-ce que
vous avez donné un mandat à votre
Ministre de régler ça et comment bon
d'abord il faut relativiser quand on
regarde dans les examens internationaux
que ça soit pour le français les
mathématiques le Québec classe toujours
bien maintenant il y a une pandémie deux
ans et demi sans amener des effets
négatifs pas seulement au Québec partout
dans le monde donc on s'attendait à ce
qu'il y a un impact sur les résultats
des examens en français mais oui de
façon générale ça fait partie du mandat
de Bernard d'améliorer la qualité de
l'enseignement du dans nos écoles parce
qu'on a l'impression que c'est une zone
oubliée souvent on parle beaucoup
beaucoup de la préservation du français
au Québec avec raison qu'on oublie la
qualité de lire plus de décrire
davantage de faire des compositions on
peut en mettre plus on peut en demander
plus à nos jeunes absolument puis on a
fait des promesses pendant la campagne
électorale entre autres de donner des
budgets à chaque enseignant pour acheter
des livres je sais moi-même une fois par
semaine de parler d'un livre que j'ai lu
c'est vrai que la lecture c'est
important pas juste pour le français
pour la réussite en mathématiques dans
tous les secteurs donc oui il faut
mettre plus d'en face sur le français
monsieur Legault est-ce que des élèves
en difficulté qu'on aurait intégré dans
les classes normales c'est pas un
immense défi pour les enseignants et
c'est ça qui les décourage est-ce qu'on
devrait pas revenir à malheureusement
ceux qui ont plus de difficultés les
mettre dans une classe à part pour que
les autres puissent décoller plus haut
ou vous en êtes je pense pas je pense
pas quand j'ai été moi-même ministre
d'éducation j'ai fait partie de ceux qui
pensaient que autant que c'est possible
il y a toujours des exceptions pour des
élèves qui ont des grandes difficultés
mais autant que possible c'est bon que
ces élèves-là soient intégrés maintenant
il faut aider les enseignants et bon
est-ce qu'il faut ajouter une deuxième
personne dans certaines classes ce qu'il
faut mettre l'accent dans certains
milieux plus défavorisés parce que
malheureusement quand on regarde les
milieux défavorisés bon puis des écoles
sont classées de 1 à 10 en fonction de
deux critères le degré de scolarité de
la mer même encore aujourd'hui en 2023
revenus moyen des parents il y a des
secteurs des écoles d'options classés 8
9 10 où il faut mettre plus de
ressources bon il faut trouver des
enseignants ou ça peut être des
éducatrices des gens qui ont un
certificat en éducation etc donc l'idée
ça va être de faire entrer dans les
écoles des gens qui ont pas
nécessairement des diplômes mais pour
venir aider au plus vite on a commencé
temporaire l'idée c'est pas
de baisser des standards c'est devenir
combler un besoin temporaire de façon
créative bon l'autre dossier que vous
avez sur votre bureau c'est la santé
c'est une évidence avec les urgences qui
déborde mais en oeuvre Rosemont mais
d'abord l'entente avec Ottawa pour qu'on
comprenne bien le 7 février s'il y a une
date ça veut dire que vous lui avez
parlé hier soir vous êtes à 98% sur une
entente bon j'ai une bonne rencontre
avec Monsieur Trudeau juste avant Noël
j'ai dit que j'étais optimiste j'ai
parlé hier soir j'étais encore optimiste
ce que j'ai dit essentiellement monsieur
Trudeau c'est que nous on a un plan le
plan de Christian Dubé puis moi j'ai
besoin d'être pour financer ce plan-là
il est pas question que le fédéral
Vienne changer notre plan je pense qu'on
a un bon plan mais on a besoin d'aide et
on a un front commun des provinces je
suis optimiste sur la rencontre du 7
février mais ça veut dire quoi vous êtes
optimal il y a des textes qui circulent
les
[Musique]
les secteurs ouvrent là où on veut
investir en pratique ce qui est
important à la fin de la journée là
c'est que le plan qu'on a dessiné qu'on
ne change pas puisqu'elle fédéral
viennent nous aider à le financer ben
c'est ce que les citoyens aimeraient
absolument parce que des urgences c'est
le cas de le dire
ok mais les chiffres sont sur la table
ça vous vole ça vous fait sourire on les
a pas encore mais enfin ça fait des
années qu'on disait monsieur Trudeau
pouvez-vous mettre au jeu quelque chose
puis je vais non je veux être bien clair
avec vous là il y a pas question de
signer le 7 on va avoir une proposition
7 on va avoir une session de travail 7
février mais c'est pas prévu qu'on signe
le 7 février et peut-être vous enfermer
toute la nuit signée ça c'est déjà vu
comme ça on a discuté de l'approche
juste un mois hôpital maison neuve
Rosemont c'est peut-être l'endroit le un
des pires laisse de Montréal
pas assez de lit pour desservir la
population il y a un projet
d'agrandissement depuis 10 ans que ça va
être annoncé c'est retardé retardé là ça
va être en plusieurs phases allez-vous
accélérer ça au cours des prochaines
années claires il y a à peu près je
pense
540-550 lits faut augmenter ça à 720
litres il est pas question de réduire
l'objectif d'aller à 720i maintenant on
avait déjà réservé dans notre plan deux
milliards et demi c'est quand même pas
rien mais il y a des dépassements de
coûts on est en train de les regarder
mais on va réaliser l'objectif d'avoir
720i à maisonneuve-rosement parce que
dans l'est de Montréal les besoins ont
beaucoup augmenté dernièrement il y a
une crise qui ne se résorbe pas en même
temps qu'on avance plus est-ce que
l'argent du fédéral va aider ou ça n'a
rien à voir et je pense ça a rien à voir
pour l'instant évidemment pour
l'équilibre de nos finances publiques
c'est important l'argent du fédéral mais
c'est important mais en oeuvreusement
les aider parce que actuellement compte
tenu de l'augmentation du volume c'est
plus difficile par exemple qu'au chemin
bon et en plus le Chine c'est plus
attirant pour le personnel parce que
c'est neuf donc il faut effectivement
être capable de les aider on est en
train je pense Christian actuellement
transfert 20% des ambulances qui vont
ailleurs vous avez une bonne cote
monsieur Legault près des Québécois vous
venez de gagner une élection monsieur
Dubé une bonne cote mais m'emmener
est-ce que vous êtes conscient que pour
la santé il va falloir que vous livriez
que les indicateurs aillent mieux madame
Bourassa qui a su faire trois jours
c'est sympa de bon sens
ce qui est arrivé maintenant la femme de
Robert boissa là c'est inacceptable puis
j'ai demandé qu'à Sainte-Marie on
s'assure que on règle ce problème là
parce que c'est un vrai ça arrive à
d'autres problèmes maintenant
je parle régulièrement avec Dark Ford
avec les premiers ministres on vit tous
le même problème de pénurie
d'infirmières ça prend quand même au
moins trois ans de cégep formés une
infirmière donc lorsqu'on a fait ce
qu'on a augmenté les salades de certains
quarts de travail on a formé des
préposés au bénéficiaires ont été encore
en négociation que les autres
professionnels pour déléguer des actes
des infirmières vers les infirmières
auxiliaires donc entre autres Sonia
label ont un rôle très important mais on
n'arrivera pas à régler le problème du
jour au lendemain mais notre plein est
là qu'on va y arriver comment vous
faites pour que les infirmières
n'aillent pas travailler au privé
puisqu'on dit c'est une pénurie oui il y
en a beaucoup mais avant au privé
moi là j'ai aucun intérêt à prendre une
infirmière du privé à donner une cote à
une entreprise privée plutôt que de
payer cet argent-là directement à
l'infirmière par contre si demain matin
je vais embaucher une infirmière
façon ponctuelle j'en ai besoin demain à
un salaire plus élevé que la convention
collective j'ai pas le droit de le faire
donc dans les négociations avec les
syndicats en particulier que l'Afrique
va falloir aller chercher plus de
flexibilité parce que moi je veux je me
donne deux objectifs puis Christian
aussi puis d'agences privées puis plus
de temps supplémentaire obligatoire
est-ce que vous dites aux syndicat au
Québec aussi il est temps que vous soyez
plus souple également la Condens ça
prend deux si j'avais à me donner un
objectif aller convention collective se
termine de 31 mars 2023 c'est celui-là
allez chercher plus de flexibilité
fabrication des horaires de façon locale
d'être capable d'avoir une meilleure
concertation regardez ce qui se passe
dans les hôpitaux anglophones il y a des
infirmières qui ont plus d'anciennetés
travaillent plus la nuit la fin de
semaine faut être capable d'avoir la
participation que tout le monde si on
veut y arriver il est au Québec monsieur
Legault allez-vous
acceptez-vous de tenir une commission
parlementaire sur l'avenir énergétique
du Québec et allez-vous inviter sophie
Brochu bon d'abord ce qui est important
de dire c'est qu'en mars 2022 on a
déposé l'Assemblée nationale le plan
stratégique 2022 2026 qui était préparé
par sophie Brochu donc le plan
d'Hydro-Québec ça a été à l'unanimité
transférait en commission la Commission
va se pencher sur ce plan stratégique
maintenant
ces projets plus existants qu'on a au
Québec on a besoin d'électrifier le
Québec ça ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'il faut être capable de mettre de
l'électricité dans le transport les
entreprises industrielles les bâtiments
l'agriculture pour arriver à s'obser
dans le plan qui était déposé par sophie
Brochu on a besoin de 100 terres à boîte
heure de plus ça veut dire une
augmentation de 50% de la capacité
actuelle d'Hydro-Québec je veux dire ça
efficacité énergétique et un lien
possiblement
c'est déjà dans le plan si vous allez
lire le plan 22 26 c'est déjà dans le
plan maintenant
barrage
négociation internationale je vous dis
dans les prochaines semaines je vais
m'asseoir avec Andrew Fury le Premier
ministre du nouveau voyant de Terre
Neuve j'ai déjà parlé on s'est parlé il
y a quelques jours puis on est d'accord
pour se rencontrer d'ici quelques
semaines puis là il y a un dossier très
important si on veut décarboner
100% l'économie du Québec si 2050 on a
un contrat qui finit en 2041 donc
qu'est-ce qui arrive en 2041 faut qu'on
négocie ça maintenant votre objectif
monsieur Lego c'est de développer avec
eux une autre rivière aussi c'est
un des projets qui est intéressant ça
s'appelle gold Island c'est sur le
territoire
de Terre-Neuve Labrador et c'est un beau
projet
que vous l'aigriez on a Hydro-Québec ont
aussi 4 5 projets sur le territoire du
Québec donc on peut rien moi je veux pas
les négocier avec Terre-Neuve en disant
j'ai absolument besoin de votre
électricité je veux avoir dans ma poche
un plan B en disant ben si ça marche pas
nous on va en faire un barrage et il
faut que j'aille ça dans ma poche et ça
fait partie des discussions que Sophie
vous avez dit à dit au Québécois il faut
faire attention cependant de pas entre
guillemets donner aux alumineries ce
qu'on fait depuis 40 ans au Québec à
moins de 4 scène le kilowatt-heure et ça
vous coûte de l'argent par emploi il y a
44000 pièces par emploi et vous a dit
attention ça a été là le début de la fin
pour elle
moi je suis d'abord
100% d'accord avec Sophie de dire il y a
eu des contrats dans le passé que ça
soit avec des olumineries ou d'autres
entreprises qui ont été signés bon faut
dire qu'à l'époque il y avait des
surplus d'électricité la partie du
moment où on a plus de surplus
d'électricité qu'on a besoin de
construire
honnêtement l'homme moi j'ai eu beaucoup
de conversations avec Sophie dans les
derniers mois et on est tous les deux
d'accord un faut des carboniques Québec
donc enlever 100% des GS 2 accepter de
financer des projets si il y a des
retombées qui accèdent le rabais qui est
demandé sur l'électricité ok est-ce que
elle va venir comme si on parlementaire
Sophie quitte le 11 avril le 11 avril
donc elle a démissionné actuellement le
conseil d'administration que les emplois
supérieurs sont en train de trouver un
remplaçant une remplaçant l'avez-vous
trouvé non pas encore moi j'ai pas en
tout cas d'indication sur qui m'ont pas
recommandé de nom mais écoutez quand il
y aura une commission parlementaire
quand il y aura l'étude des crédits ce
printemps et là on verra ce qu'on est
encore avec sophie Brochu à la tête
d'Hydro c'est une nouvelle personne mais
moi j'ai pas de problème puis
honnêtement je ne peux pas pour faire un
jeu facile votre barrage qui viennent
je ne sens pas de différent sur les
orientations avec ça
allez-vous aller plaider devant la Cour
suprême le grand du Québec en disant on
a le droit de l'utiliser avant pendant
après bon d'abord hier soir je vais
parler avec Justin Trudeau j'ai abordé
ce sujet là parce que je lui ai dit là
que ça a pas de bon sens que
on remet en question l'utilisation de la
clause dérogatoire qui permet entre
autres au gouvernement du Québec de
protéger des droits collectifs
fondamentaux comme protéger le français
au Québec
à des anglophones ou des allophones la
langue de travail au Québec c'est le
français peut-être que certaines
personnes peuvent penser ça va contre
leur droit individuels mais ils ont le
droit de le penser ils ont le droit de
le penser mais nous on a le droit le
Parlement puis moi j'ai un mandat fort
je suis le seul premier ministre d'un
gouvernement qui représente une majorité
de francophones en Amérique j'ai le
devoir de m'assurer qu'on arrête le
déclin du français et je peux vous dire
une chose Monsieur roi là c'est dans mes
priorités puis on va dans les prochains
mois posé des nouveaux gestes comme au
sujet s'assurer non pour ça le plus
important c'est l'immigration ok parce
que on fait pas beaucoup d'enfants au
Québec donc si on veut être capable
d'arrêter de décliner du français faut
absolument qu'on augmente le pourcentage
de francophones chez les immigrants les
gouvernements qui ont été là avant nous
parce que québécois et partie libéral
que les nouveaux arrivants il y en a
seulement 50%
nous on a déjà augmenté 180% si on veut
protéger 80% de francophones au Québec
faut au moins 80% des nouveaux
immigrants si ce sont les français si ce
sont des francophones qui arrivent vous
pouvez monter votre seuil de 50 000
si ce sont des francophones c'est
quelque chose qu'on peut considérer ok
maintenant notre absence que ça va venir
mettre du de la du brouillage sur la
ligne pour la santé avec Monsieur
Trudeau bon d'abord
l'objectif que Justin avait déjà dit
c'est qui il y a pas la loi 21 la loi 96
ce que je vous parle du côté de
l'immigration on peut très bien avec les
pouvoirs qu'on a actuellement
s'assurer qu'on sélectionne plus de
francophones donc il y a des gestes
qu'on peut poser mais maintenant
d'aller revoir la clause nonobstacle qui
est dans constitution sans l'accord du
Québec j'ai la designer que ça va
arriver les prochaines années ça va
prendre du temps avant qu'on se rend
compte que là
mais on va se battre moi je vais me
battre on a besoin de la clause de
l'Oratoire c'est sûr qu'on a jamais
signé à construction donc ça serait
quand même le comble de nous enlever ça
mais votre relation avec le fédéral a
quand même changé parce que sur
l'immigration vous aviez dit sans tous
les pouvoirs on va devenir la Louisiane
puis là vous dites j'ai pas besoin de
nouveaux pouvoirs on va mieux les gérer
vous avez changé le Québec à 60% des
pouvoirs d'immigration ok l'immigration
économique il y a
l'immigration réunification familiale et
les réfugiés puis on a le gros l'immense
problème de Roxane actuellement 36000
personnes qui passent par exemple puis
là il faut arrêter ça donc j'ai besoin
du fédéral j'ai besoin que dans 40% qui
est choisi par le fédéral qui est plus
de francophones sur le goal il nous
reste une minute 10 des petites vitres
rencontre avec Monsieur poirievre
bientôt oui ou non
je lui ai parlé au téléphone il y a
quelques mois mais bon
j'ai pas rien de prévu pour l'instant
pensez-vous qu'il allait avoir qu'on va
avoir des élections fédérales en 2023
je ne sais pas plus que lui
on est dans une école monsieur Legault
dans mettre plus une heure de sport par
jour est-ce que c'est possible moi c'est
mon fantasme
d'ailleurs si vous rappelez bien en 2018
on avait promis d'ajouter 5 heures par
semaine dans toutes les écoles
secondaires qu'on ne le fait on dit pour
faire trois choses du sport des arts
aussi parce qu'il y a des enfants qui
aiment mieux des activités artistiques
puis d'aide aux devoir donc on le fait
puis là on va investir un milliard et
demi dans des infrastructures sportives
c'est un autre engagement de la campagne
électorale Isabelle charrette travaille
très fort
de toutes les idées des chefs de
l'opposition parce que là vous avez
comme une collaboration il y a des
petits oiseaux partout tout le monde
s'entend bien quelle idée vous dites ça
je vois la prendre de qui ben écoutez on
va on est en train on est en train de
les regarder mais je vous dirai vous
parliez tantôt de la commission
parlementaire sur
la transition énergétique c'est certain
j'ai parlé à tous les chefs est-ce que
vous êtes ouvert à des barrages c'est
important qu'on travaille ensemble j'ai
pas aimé le débat que qu'il y a eu le
supposément de sophie Brochu pierre on a
tous besoin au Québec de travailler
ensemble à décarboner le Québec quand je
vois certains partis politiques qui
durant la campagne électorale disait
d'ici 2030 on va pas réduire les gestes
de 37 et demi on va réduire de 55 %,
mais c'est pas possible on n'a pas assez
directricité d'ici 2030 donc ces gens
d'échange qu'on a eu en privé
je pense que c'est bénéfique et je vais
continuer ça donc une grande un grand
lieu où on pourra discuter de ça
merci beaucoup monsieur au revoir